as of last week a tesla can be paid for
with bitcoin
as of this week all fire ship courses
can be paid for with bitcoin and as of
the end of this video
your product can also be paid for with
bitcoin i've always been pretty
skeptical of crypto but the more i work
with it as a developer and the more the
fed runs the money printer the more i
like it
but most importantly i want to give my
customers choice if the customer wants
to pay with bitcoin
ethereum litecoin or whatever they
should have that option
in today's video you'll learn how to
implement cryptocurrency payments on the
web
using the coinbase commerce api giving
you the ability to receive crypto
payments in a variety of different
formats first of all how does a
cryptocurrency payment work
well unlike a credit card payment which
is processed by a central authority
a crypto payment gets broadcast to a
peer-to-peer network around the world
where miners compete with their
computing power to confirm that
transaction on the blockchain
that process can take time maybe 10
minutes or so before the transaction is
fully confirmed on coinbase commerce
the first thing you'll do is create a
charge which is more like a payment
intent
it has an amount and description and can
be denominated in us dollars when a
charge is created it has a lifespan of
one hour
and coinbase in the background will
monitor the payment networks
looking for a payment to be confirmed on
this charge the charge
also provides a url hosted by coinbase
where the user can either pay with
crypto or their coinbase account
now after the user submits their payment
coinbase will fire a web hook
that can notify your server that the
charge is now pending
it's at that point that you can notify
the customer that the payment has been
received and we're just waiting for the
final confirmation on the blockchain
before we ship it out at some point in
the future
coinbase will see the transaction is
confirmed and will send another web hook
to your server
notifying you that everything is good to
go unless something went wrong
like a user may have overpaid or
underpaid because crypto is so volatile
or maybe they accidentally made multiple
payments on the same charge in which
case you'll need to manually resolve the
charge
things like that shouldn't happen often
but those are just some of the caveats
to be aware of when working with crypto
in addition to coinbase commerce you
might also look into bitpay
or coingate as alternatives or if you
want to use a currency that's designed
specifically for
digital transactions you might want to
look into something like kim
to get started the first thing you'll
need is to own a little bit of crypto
i'm not saying that to try to pump
bitcoin or anything but because coinbase
commerce doesn't actually have a sandbox
for testing payments so in order to test
your implementation you'll need to have
a wallet with some crypto in it the
easiest way to do that is by setting up
a coinbase account and if you use my
referral link in the description you and
i both will get a 10
referral reward and this video is not
sponsored by the way i actually use
coinbase commerce for the implementation
on fireship io in any case
the next thing you'll need is a coinbase
commerce account when you create an
account it will automatically generate a
wallet for different cryptocurrencies
like ethereum bitcoin litecoin etc
allowing other users to send you money
on these respective blockchains
on the dashboard you'll get a breakdown
of all your payments and one thing
that's worth pointing out is that if you
have a static product where the pricing
doesn't change
you can create a checkout and then embed
it directly in your fronted application
without having to write any client-side
code but in this demo we'll do it the
more developer oriented way
by creating a charge that can handle
dynamic pricing and data
to add coinbase to a backend server
we'll need to go to the settings tab
and create an api key this key is how
you access your coinbase account from a
server and it should never be exposed in
your front end code
but now we need a server and my favorite
way to get one into production quickly
is with firebase cloud functions sign up
for a firebase account
and install the firebase command line
tools then run firebase edit functions
from the command line
that'll give us a node.js project in the
functions directory
go ahead and cd into it then we can
install the coinbase commerce sdk for
node
and at the same time install cores or
cross origin resource sharing
so we can make requests to this function
from a frontend application
in the javascript code we can import the
coinbase commerce client
as well as resources the client is used
to identify our project with coinbase
which we do by calling client init with
our secret api key
now there are many different things you
can do with the api but we're interested
in creating a charge which is available
from the resources object from there we
can start defining our cloud function
which is just an http endpoint that we
can call from any application
to call it from the browser we'll need
to enable course which we can do by
importing the course library
and setting the origin to the wild card
character then we can pass the request
and response objects to cores
and define the business logic inside of
its callback now normally you probably
get some data from the request like a
product id
and then go and fetch that product from
a database somewhere but in this case
we'll define our charge data
as just a generic widget that's priced
at 9.99
one useful tip here is that you can
store metadata like a user id
if you want to reference the user in the
future when changes happen to the charge
then to create a charge on coinbase we
simply call await
charge create with that data and then
send it back down to the client as the
response
once that charge is created the user
then has one hour to make their payment
let's go ahead and see the charge in
action by running firebase serve to
serve the function on localhost 5000.
now let's build a frontend application
with vanilla javascript in this
index.html file and you can get all the
source code for this project on github
by the way
the html just has a button that says buy
something with crypto
below the button we have a script that
makes a reference to the button
and when it's clicked it will fire off a
request to the cloud function
endpoint using the fetch api and will
convert its response to json which
contains all the charge data from
coinbase
there's a bunch of useful data on it
like the current exchange rate and the
entire timeline of the charge itself
but to get the customer to pay we need
to show them the hosted url
which contains the addresses and qr
codes to our crypto wallet
and allows the user to connect their own
coinbase account if they prefer
if the user decides not to pay the
charge will expire after an hour but if
they do pay we then need to listen to
web hooks from coinbase
when the payment is initially sent but
not confirmed we'll get a charge pending
web hook
but in order to listen to web hooks we
need to have a url that's available on
the internet
that coinbase can send data to go back
to the settings panel on coinbase
commerce and click the button to
show shared secret under webhook
subscriptions whenever coinbase sends a
webhook to our server it signs the
request
and we can use this secret to verify
that the request is valid
no matter what api you're working with
it's always very important to
validate the signature because otherwise
any hacker could then pretend to be
coinbase and send web hooks to your
server and you wouldn't know the
difference
back in our code we'll set up a second
http cloud function called webhook
handler
the first thing it'll do is grab the raw
body of the request
which is just the request in a binary
format along with the signature which is
contained in a header on the request
and lastly we'll make a reference to the
webhook secret that we got from the
coinbase dashboard from there we can set
up a try catch block to catch any errors
that might happen when verifying the
signature
we can pass these three values to
webhook verify event body
which verifies that this request
actually did come from coinbase
it returns us with the event data from
coinbase which itself will have a type
like pending confirmed or failed and
also contains data about the current
state of the charge
which you'll want to use to implement
your own business logic on fireship for
example
i immediately grant access to pro
content when the charge is pending by
updating a database
but if the charge fails or becomes
unresolved for whatever reason then i
revoke access and take steps to resolve
it the logic here is highly dependent on
whatever it is you're selling if you
sell a physical product for example you
might want to print a shipping label
after the charge is confirmed
i think we're about ready to ship this
baby off to production go ahead and run
firebase deploy from the command line
which will give you a url
for the webhook handler now go back to
the coinbase dashboard
and set up that url as your web hook
subscription congratulations
you can now accept crypto payments from
your customers i'm going to go ahead and
wrap things up there
make sure to like and subscribe and
consider supporting this content by
buying a lifetime membership with crypto
for any one of my individual courses
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one